and
[Music]
now the real fun in audio for your
project is sound design and we're not
talking about just throwing in a few
sound effects here we're talking about
the creation of new custom sounds that
are designed for your piece so where do
we start well there are two aspects of
sound design that you need to consider
the creative one and the technical one
let's get technical first technical
technical technical so let's say we want
to create a sound in designing one we
combine a bunch of different sounds to
generate something new but they need to
be balanced so that the elements in each
sound you want to hear can be heard
usually you just can't stack a dozen
sounds on top of each other so every
sound you hear covers a full range of
frequencies but we only hear the
strongest aspects of them imagine an
equalizer we have highs mids and lows
and if you're creating a sound you need
to make sure that each sound you combine
isn't occupying the entire spectrum you
don't want to combine two sounds with a
lot of bass because then you just get a
bunch of garbling bass garbling this can
be achieved by using sounds that are
naturally on different ends of the
spectrum or you can force them to be
like that with an equalizer all right so
what about the creative side of things
the creative process is really all about
abstraction finding ways to make great
sounds regardless of whether they're
actually from the actual source or not
you'll often hear how gunfire sound
effects are combined with cannon fire
or how crunching eggshells can be used
for someone eating potato chips
okay so let's say we want to make a
really cool punch sound effect for a
very important scene yeah let's do it
ready
what elements do we need for a good
punch sound effect because that didn't
work first a nice slow impact oh wait
i got just the thing
nico be my guest
[Music]
look at all the dust coming off this
building this is a really dusty pillow
but it sounds great
well that's one element
second let's get a mid-range element for
that crack this is really going to be
the body of the sound so just just smack
it nico smack it
try it again
punch it maybe punch it or something
that's limp wrists
punch it
there you go one of those is probably
good all right all right and lastly
we're gonna use a wet paper towel slap
this might seem a little bit weird but
it'll help really sell the skin on skin
action we're getting there from punch so
let's try this out
this is how they do it this is how the
pros do it
no this is how the pro is this other
person i can't wait to hear what this
sounds like
wait can i make a sound
here wet towel slap sound
[Music]
so i hope you guys learned something if
you guys liked the video leave a comment
and subscribe
okay so we stack all these things
together and they sound kind of cool you
may have noticed we have taken three
sounds that are naturally in different
ranges high mids and lows but we can
make them better with our eq because
each sound is still leading into each
other
look how great that sounds but we're
just getting started just getting
started there's one more thing i'd like
to talk about for sound design that's
heads and tails just because the sound
happens quickly doesn't mean it has to
be over what what heads and tails that's
the sounds before and after your sound
effect actually happens but a bunch of
so quick but check out how much cooler
this is going to sound with heads and
tails
make me a wush sound a wish action will
help sell the motion of the punch
whoosh
so we got a whoosh for the beginning a
whoosh into the punch and a little bit
of crunching and squishing for the
aftermath will help for a lingering pain
feeling oh i have just the thing
lingering pain squish take two
oops it's very much more wet than i
expected so you know you have a punch
and you have like a whoosh sound before
that punch you might think you want like
an airy whoosh like if you take a stick
and like swing it through the air like a
broom handle but instead think of it
instead as the whoosh of cloth sliding
against itself
because that's actually more what you're
hearing your hands are moving so fast
leaving air wishes you're actually just
getting cloth washes
that's a well-designed sound yeah that
was good so not having good heads and
tails the common mistake people make
when doing gun sound effects exactly the
most interesting part of the gunshot
sound is actually the tail when reverb
and crackles and all that kind of stuff
it's not that first crack with a
microphone blowing out that part's
whatever yeah it's like
[Music]
you see hits and tails
the most interesting part of that
gunshot is the tail and that click where
you get those cool guns and the reverb
crackle not the actual microphone don't
forget don't forget the ringing of the
brass the ringing of the brass crinkling
on the ground yes there's so many
aspects that happened before and after
the gunshot you want to consider so
think about it an actual gunshot is
literally just a loud bang that lasts
for like half a frame it's just like
that's what a real gun sounds like when
you uh don't have a cool environment to
shoot on
yeah so we hope you got hurt
so we hope you guys learned something
from this video i believe that someday
you will all become pros at this you'll
know you've made it when you can create
a sound design with emotion in it and
other fancy topics but that's a whole
nother video if you guys enjoyed this
video or have any questions leave a
comment below or send us a tweet on
twitter at corridor digital also if you
like the sweet t-shirts that we usually
wear in videos not this particular one
you can check out cordoradeshdigital.com
to purchase one
for yourself
and your friends so between all these
videos i hope you guys are off to a good
start in your sound journeys and
hopefully this improves the quality of
your videos because
you know
i've seen a few of them
yep that's all from us in the dolby
institute thanks for watching guys until
next time bye
anyways like that
just because a sound happens quickly
doesn't mean it's gotta be over
just like how i wish the matrix never
ended